how do we get to the place where
you know putin decides he's going to
just invade russia nothing like this has
happened since world war ii
well there you have it people it is a
very solemn day a solemn weekend and a
solemn monday now
there was president joe biden over the
weekend
telling us how vladimir putin
the president of russia
he's invaded russia
all right so we didn't know about this
we didn't know i've been watching the
news you know what i mean i got my guys
sending me things throughout the day i'm
on all of the social media platforms i
had not been informed we knew things
were getting bad right everybody knew
something was going on and this putin
guy something's not right
but according to the president of the
united states he has now
invaded his own country okay something
like this has not happened since world
war ii
all right can we go back to that one
more time because i don't want to just
you know gloss over the gravity of the
situation here
how do we get to the place where
you know putin decides he's going to
just invade russia nothing like this has
happened since world war ii
i don't know how we get to this place
it's a bad place to be we did not want
to be in this place
where putin invaded his own country
and on top of everything else going on
with ukraine
and all the other stuff
energy prices etc it's pretty bad
ladles and jelly spoons it's march 7th
2022 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message we are live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
and of course what i just did there was
a playoff of what the man pretending to
be president is doing every single day
which is just flubbing everything
constantly obviously that was just a
slip of the tongue
but at some point people at some point i
think we're all going to have to say
we got a big problem here because
supposedly that guy
is in charge uh we're going to be
talking all about energy today because
that really is the part of this ukraine
russia thing that is affecting us here
in the united states and really
affecting everybody all over the world
um i was in los angeles as you may
remember on friday we pre-taped our q a
i was in los angeles for a few hours i
got in and out as quickly as i could
because i was taping my next prageru
video which will coincide with the debut
of dumper in this country in april we've
got a couple pictures of what i saw in
los angeles this is related to all the
energy stuff that's going on first off
this is a picture i took of the gas
station near the prageru offices and
look at those freaking gas prices okay
those are bananas prices 549 for regular
absolutely insane los angeles is just an
absolute dystopian
crap haul and i know i have to put in
cash into the fleeing california fund
whenever i talk about california i did
try to buy coffee in california and i
was rejected yeah that's when i went
into
uh what was that that was pan cote d'in
i think i'm pronouncing it correctly
was rejected there i was also rejected
from buying an iced coffee at the
airport at lax itself because i went up
to coffee bean and tea leaf and i said
to the lady i would like a large iced
coffee with some oat milk and she said
sir i can't serve you unless you put
your mask on and i swear to you i am not
making this up this is not a joke
michael was there he can confirm it
uh i said to her
well ma'am the president of the united
states joe biden did not wear a mask at
the state of the union in that room with
all of those other people just a few
days ago and she literally was like this
her eyes actually crossed like i
actually created some sort of vortex in
her brain she could not understand how
those things were connected
like this
and uh yadda yadda i had to get in the
uber without iced coffee i was not happy
about it all that being said uh the
prageru video i think you're really
gonna dig it i believe it comes out on
april 11th am i allowed to say that and
the book comes out on april 12th which
reminds me to tell you it and then we
will get to all the stuff
that we're going to get to on today's
show uh don't burn this country comes
out on april 12th you can pre-order
right now at daverubin.com
book i think you're going to dig it it's
just the next steps in everything that i
laid out in don't burn this book it's
now how you can fix your own life to the
best of your ability
in this woke dystopia that we are in and
for the next three days in case
increasingly over the course of this
week you hear my voice getting weaker
and softer and hoarser and i'm
talking like that it's because for the
next three days for five hours a day
when i get out of here uh basically uh
afternoon right after this uh i'm doing
the audiobook which i am reading myself
i really loved reading it last time and
i know a lot of you guys liked it that
way i can get the humor right and the
inflection and the tone and all that but
it's five hours a day for three days
might even be four days just depending
on how it all goes uh so i'll be doing
that uh every day this week and as i
said the book comes out on april 12th
all right so let's uh let's just get to
it here we all know something ain't
right there's a lot of things that ain't
right and there's a lot of things that
ain't been right for a long time whether
we're talking about covet and lockdowns
and firing people and mandates and
supply chain stuff and afghanistan and
really nothing's working as it's
supposed to uh but uh prices of gas
right now are going completely insane
should we do that video first the video
from la we'll do the video first let's
so here's a little from a local la
news station when will it end
yes they're outrageous man yeah the los
angeles long beach area broke another
record again today for the highest
average we are now paying 488 for a
gallon of regular unleaded so bad tow
truck drivers seeing a trend maybe
that's why i do a lot of fuel calls
tonight because people can't afford gas
people i do four or five fuel calls at
night you know
you gotta love truck drivers you really
gotta like the guy's got a great sense
of humor like basically like ah people
don't wanna drive their cars anymore
because of the gas prices so they're
calling me to tow their uh to tow their
cars so uh statista uh has compiled gas
prices uh for the last two years well
they've been compiling it for the last
you know many years but starting in
november of 2020 they started this chart
here no i'm sorry this is january of 19
is where they started the chart and as
you can see gas prices
they dipped out interestingly this is
really interesting they dipped out in
about may of 20. so this is now orange
man was president we're sort of at the
height of covid but gas prices were
under control and then i want i want you
to look at
is basically january of 21 and just a
little bit before that november of 20
you see that that was when we had the
election and then january of 21 is when
joe biden is installed president of the
united states and gas prices have gone
bananas since then gas prices of course
these are the barometer the real
barometer of what actually
is going on in the country right like
when things are going pretty well and
the economy is pretty stable gas prices
are basically pretty low and now we are
watching them explode so you don't have
to know everything about macroeconomics
you don't have to know everything about
supply chain or anything else to
understand why gas prices
and trucks need to move things people
need to drive to work like that gas in
essence is the fuel of the economy for
lack of a better phrase so prices are
completely blowing up right now now why
would they be blowing up is this all
just because of what's happening just
because as joe biden said vladimir putin
invaded russia could it all just be
because of that or could there be
something else a bit more nefarious
going on here well here's biden's energy
secretary jennifer granholm
talking about how we have to transition
out of gas but what when did that happen
but the bottom line is that this
president and this administration are
looking at every single tool to shield
american families from the impact of
rising energy prices and we're working
through
we're working through an energy
transition
and we've got to start by adding energy
and the reality is we have to take some
time to get off of oil and gas we
recognize this this is a transition
you see what she just did right there
she said the quiet part out loud uh lady
first off they're using every single
tool well no they're not using every
single tool they're basically not using
any of our tools we're now talking to
iran about getting oil we're talking to
venezuela about getting oil we uh are
not
talking to texas we're not talking about
the keystone pipeline that buy it and
closed right we're not doing the things
that would make us energy independent
which we easily could be everyone knows
this we'll get
more to that
in a few minutes everyone knows this we
are not doing every single thing we can
but what she said there
was uh
about the transition
that's the interesting thing this energy
transition and now i think ladies and
gentlemen we are peeling the onion a bit
a little bit and what we're gonna find
is this thing really stinks um
energy transition now we can all talk
about aoc's green new deal and all of
the stuff that they've been pushing on
us and the transition to solar and wind
and all of those things and how they
don't really work properly and often
just become crazy boondoggles of
government putting in money to things
and a lot of people get rich but it
doesn't really do much of anything okay
in theory am i for green energy and
renewable resources of course you really
want to do it right we should be
building nuclear plants but let's put
that aside for just a second this idea
that they're using this crisis and this
is what government does
always with everything they see a crisis
right now and by the way there is a
crisis so contrary to what joe biden
said
putin the president of russia he did not
invade russia he invented he invaded
ukraine okay now the problem there is
now we are putting all sorts of
sanctions the world is putting all sorts
of sanctions on russia
over the weekend mastercard and visa
said that they won't do financial
transactions with russia russia's
feeling the pinch but we are also still
buying gas from russia right now so in
some ways you could argue that we are
partially funding the war we're kind of
on both sides of this thing we're giving
ukraine weapons we're helping them on
the ground
etc etc and we're also buying
oil from the guys who are doing the
invading
now again if you want to get off oil
altogether we can have that conversation
if you want to get off fossil fuels
altogether
have that conversation these guys never
want to talk about nuclear by the way
they never never want to talk about
nuclear
but this is what they're doing they are
taking this crisis and they are saying
see russia's bad russia has something to
do with oil and gas and energy and this
is our opportunity to transition away
from this stuff altogether do you think
this might be connected to that great
reset thing or is that possibly just a
crazy crazy conspiracy theory that seems
to unfold further into truth every
single day well jen saki continued uh
she went on you know i love this sake
woman
she's blaming the increasing prices here
at home which again should not be
increasing because we have enough oil if
we could just release our natural
resources
she's blaming it all on putin and
ukraine the reason why the price of gas
is going up is not because of steps the
president has taken they are because
president putin is invading ukraine and
that is creating a great deal of
instability in the global marketplace
really jen really you're not going to
believe this we did a little research
phoenix
good for you today we did a little
research and gas prices actually rose a
dollar 14
from biden's inauguration to the day
putin invaded that is also according to
statista so what she's saying right now
is you're seeing gas prices rise they're
rising but it's because of that putin
guy you know he's in charge of russia
and the old man said he invaded russia
and that's why except for the year plus
that joe biden has been president gas
prices were already rising and we were
not doing anything to rely on ourselves
so we are buying just really understand
this right now and and
really not only really understand it but
then really think about what's really
going on here it's like we are buying
gas from russia while russia is
attacking ukraine now you could say we
should have nothing to do with any of
this we should be completely independent
we shouldn't have anything to do
militarily with any of this we can have
all of those conversations but just know
what we're doing and that our leaders
are just lying to us about why prices
are going up now you may remember a
certain orange man with crazy hair he
was president for four years then they
booted him from social media they sent
him to the phantom zone but occasionally
we can find old video clips and in most
of these old video clips for some reason
he's getting most of the stuff
right so here is former president donald
trump at the u.n general assembly you
know they hold this charade every year
where mostly bad countries come to
lecture the rest of us but the president
speaks at it every year this is a couple
years back at the u.n general assembly
president donald trump
calling out a whole bunch of countries
for relying on russian oil
reliance on a single foreign supplier
can leave a nation vulnerable
to extortion and intimidation
that is why we congratulate
european states such as poland
for leading the construction of a baltic
pipeline so that nations are not
dependent on russia
to meet their energy needs
germany will become totally dependent
on russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
here in the western hemisphere
we are committed
to maintaining our independence
from the encroachment
of expansionist foreign powers
did you catch what happened right at the
end there that when they flash to the
u.n people from germany and they're kind
of smiling and laughing as trump says
that
that germany's in a lot of trouble
because you shouldn't be so reliant
on russia and they're laughing it off
well it's like
pretty sure nobody's laughing right now
all countries should try to be as energy
independent as possible so you aren't
relying on other countries right so
other countries don't have leverage over
you now look some countries don't have a
lot of natural resources it's it just is
what it is so you have to figure out
ways to innovate you have to figure out
partnerships with other countries that
make sense you have to think about oil
you have to think about gas you have to
think about fracking you have to think
about nuclear wind power water power all
of those things depends on your
geography depends on your people your
level of innovation all of that
but trump was right trump was right and
once again biden is unsure who's
invading who and why they're doing it uh
now on friday we did a little story
about elon musk and of course elon musk
from spacex and starlink and tesla he is
our he is the world's
well yes i guess he's the world's tony
stark in essence he is our most
important industrialist and technologist
right now and he is operating outside of
the government trying to get things done
so right now he's got the starlink
system operating in the ukraine so that
people are able to get internet service
um and that's not even a perfect system
because then they're worried that the
russians might be able to actually
pinpoint where people are but he's doing
his best to help keep the flow of
information open and the rest of it uh
he jumped on twitter to make a point
about what's going on here with oil and
gas let's throw up that first tweet he
said hate to say it but we need to
increase oil and gas output immediately
extraordinary times demand extraordinary
measures now he went on here's the
second tweet this is where it really
gets interesting and you can sort of see
someone's motivations every now and
again obviously this would negatively
affect tesla but sustainable energy
solutions simply cannot react
instantaneously to make up for russian
oil and gas exports
that's someone telling the truth
the truth now think about this tesla
michael you just got a tesla last week
how do you like that car
he loves the car okay he loves the car
the tesla is an awesome machine i had a
tesla when i was in la and then we left
it there because they told us we could
get one real quick when we get here
anyway it's supposed to come this week i
love the tesla it's awesome it's truly
an innovative technology and the idea
that you're not so dependent on gas and
all that stuff okay we all know that and
we know by the way that he's gotten
government subsidies and tax breaks okay
fine but what he's saying right there is
hey
i'm a guy
that is selling renewable energy cars
electric cars to get us off this oil
stuff however in a moment such as this
i am willing to put out information out
there and say we better start doing more
drilling here we better start unleashing
american energy
which is going to hurt my bottom line
right then less people will need the
tesla if we actually do that he's saying
i will i will put that out there
because there are things more important
than my bottom line that's what an
actual honest
businessman and industrialist and an
american
would say and it's extremely interesting
because the democrats are completely
against this they wanted keystone shut
down which is exactly what joe biden did
right when he took office and they
wanted us more reliant on we've got this
iran deal coming through as i said
venezuela before you've got pete budage
our gay transportation secretary and i
only mention he's gay because that's why
he got the job uh talking about how we
gonna have to think about you know
getting oil again from iran and it's
like well pete you know they throw
people like you off cranes in iran but i
guess they're not quite as bad as evil
putin right ted cruz he's down with what
uh elon musk said he said couldn't agree
more unleash american energy now you
think a guy like ted cruz might know a
little something about this he's a
senator from a small state you may have
heard of it called texas and they have a
lot of something there called oil
and if we would allow them to do the
proper drilling and again we can always
talk about how we can do all of this
stuff better right we can always talk
about are there ways to make sure that
fracking is completely safe and you're
not causing little tremors or whatever
people are worried about are we doing
all of the things to make sure we're
we're not harming the environment we're
not causing gas leaks and we're not
polluting our rivers and basically
creating the scene from the simpsons
movie can we make sure we're doing all
that stuff yes but right now relative to
what's happening in the world does it
make sense that at any level
we are reliant on anyone other than
ourselves for energy when we have the
ability
to be completely self-sustaining it just
doesn't make sense and it really doesn't
make sense that we would be buying oil
from russia right now and i'm not saying
this is someone that wants to create a
war right there's a war going on whether
we like it or not so should we be
funding the war through oil when we
could literally tomorrow
just start opening up the pipes could we
what should we do what do you think we
should do anyway all of this
is so crazy and one of the reasons it's
crazy as we've been talking about
forever here is that the media just
makes all of this impossible it is so
hard to figure out who to trust people
who could not point out russia or
ukraine on a map suddenly know exactly
what to do people who couldn't tie their
shoes if their shoes were velcro you
can't tie velcro but you get the point
uh they suddenly know everything
everyone's an expert in russia and
ukraine and everything else i'm trying
not to go over my pay grade in any of
this but just translate some basic info
to you actually by the way later we're
putting up later today right the nikki
haley interview that's later today yeah
i interviewed nikki haley on friday
with a bit of uh to get sort of a broad
look at what's going on in ukraine nikki
haley of course who was the united
states ambassador to the un uh during
the trump administration when we did not
have these wars uh so she talks about
peace through strength i also talked to
her about a lot of my libertarian
beliefs so i think you'll dig it we'll
check that out a little bit later but
it's really hard to get an honest
assessment of anything and everybody is
just talking out of their asses but then
i saw this this video went viral over
the weekend this is ufc fighter bryce
mitchell and he's being asked about
russia and ukraine because apparently if
you're a ufc fighter or you're a plumber
or a politician
or you work at the geek squad at best
buy you have to have an opinion on
absolutely everything all the time and
you're not going to believe this but ufc
fighter bryce mitchell the guy's making
some sense to get your thoughts on the
whole russia and ukraine situation
you know um
here's my first thought is i'm not going
nowhere to fight none of these wars for
these politicians i'm staying at home
and when the war comes to arkansas i
will dig my boots in the ground and i
will die for everything i love and i
will not retreat if this country is
invaded and everybody's saying well we
gotta we gotta evacuate we gotta leave
we got i will not i will dig my boots in
the arkansas soil and i will fight for
the people that i love for the land that
i love and the way life that i love but
i'm not going overseas to fight
i don't know what's going on to be
honest brother i really don't there's so
much stuff and i don't think nobody
knows what's going on fully there's been
so much political corruption in that
area you got biden and his son making a
[ __ ] ton of money
off of uh and using our tax dollars to
bribe
their people that's treasonous in my
opinion
so you got hunter biden and his son
using our tax dollars hey if if
ukrainian government if you don't do
this we're taking your tax dollars he
shouldn't be giving our tax dollars to
that country anyway we got veterans out
here sleeping on the street and you're
going to give our freaking tax dollars
to these ukrainians and all i'd rather i
don't know what's going on over there
but i'm not going over there fighting
and god bless anybody that's over there
is fighting and i hope that this [ __ ]
just gets solved and man i don't like
war
you know what i mean i don't want people
dying and all that stuff i don't want to
be but i don't know what's going on
there's so much stuff that i think
that's corrupted that we just don't know
what's truly going on over there and i
just i pray all those people are safe
there you have it people ufc fighter
bryce mitchell who i did not know of
until i saw this video making more sense
than pretty much anyone you're gonna see
on cnn or msnbc or half these other
places like what is really going on here
how did this war just explode and this
energy crisis just explode
just as kovid was wrapping up just
before the state of the union just
months before the midterms as
everybody's angry at the democrats like
what really is going on here and more
interestingly what he says is just like
the very human level like i'm not going
there i live in arkansas if someone
attacks arkansas i'll defend that he
even hits on the corruption like the
deep level of corruption in ukraine and
that is not simping for russia if you
say that okay there is deep corruption
in ukraine we know you've all seen the
video a million times right the video of
biden bragging how he was going to
withhold u.s dollars from ukraine
unless they fired the prosecutor that he
wanted fired everyone has seen it we
also weren't allowed to talk about
hunter biden's laptop before the
election and the new york post had their
twitter account suspended because they
were breaking the hunter biden story and
hunter biden was getting what was it
about 10 million bucks a month something
like that from uh barisma how much was
was it 10 million a month something like
that we're going to get the we're going
to get the numbers for you but a guy
hunter biden who was a basically a crack
addict who had no expertise
in the energy sector was getting an
awful lot of money
from a ukrainian energy company uh
before the election and we were not
allowed to talk about it we have the
numbers on that it was it was a crazy
amount of money he was getting what do
we got there i think we have a typo
he was getting a million
a million a year is that it
he was getting a million a year from
brisbane i think it was more than that
yeah all right we're gonna look we're
gonna look to get that uh cleaned up
we'll get it cleaned up for you tomorrow
um but he was getting an awful lot of
money and whether it was a million i'm
pr and i'm pretty sure it was more than
that but whether it was a million or
whether it was eight million it's like
the guy had no expertise whatsoever to
be working for a ukrainian energy
company so bryce mitchell man you make
some sense you make some sense so anyway
i was uh we were putting together the
show today and i thought well all right
this is sort of depressing at some level
like we have this sort of war brewing
that we're kind of in and also not in
but like the whole world is connected
one way or another and because we're
selling these guys these russians led by
vladimir putin because we're selling
them oil like we are all connected to
this thing right and and the energy
price is going up and we all know food
prices are going up like it feels weird
it just all feels weird and i was like
you know it's a monday
and i don't really want to just depress
people on a monday can we find something
that's going to make people sit up
straight with their shoulders back and
be like you know america's got some good
stuff going on too
well believe it or not it came from a
soccer game i i can't believe it but it
did uh this is a really beautiful moment
uh clay travis my buddy clay travis
tweeted this thing out this is in
charlotte north carolina over the
weekend at an mls soccer game
they are the the singer is singing the
national anthem and the audio goes out
and the whole stadium just picks up and
it's just absolutely beautiful take a
look
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean man how absolutely beautiful is
that right like chills up your spine
that is we the people and that's why
there still is so much goodness here i
know it's hard to pilfer out the
goodness through all the crazy news but
those are just good old-fashioned
americans and it's a beautiful moment
there's a lot of moments like that when
we can actually get together and see
each other perhaps that's why they
wanted us locked down and scared and
afraid of each other all this time uh
before we wrap up guys it is me monday
over at the reuben report locals
community at
reubenreport.locals.com here's the meme
that i put up this morning
there you go shell regular gases lol
plus omg supreme wtf and they're
providing ky jelly to help ease the pain
of your next gas purchase uh we got a
couple hundred responses on the post
already people just putting in their
favorite memes right now there is no
shortage of memes the memes will save us
basically because if you can stay happy
and and stay joyous through all this
lunacy that is actually how we will win
all right a couple comments from locals
uh dak says i legit saw gas go from 559
a gallon to 589 a gallon in a three-hour
period here in la county yeah it's nuts
it's nuts and it's like people i hope
even you crazy freaking lunatics of
california
realize that this is the policy
of your people these are the policies of
the people that you elect whether it's
the governor and his ridiculous policies
related to energy or it's the president
of the united states so i was even
thinking when i was coming back when i
was on a plane and i was like i felt
like i was escaping california and i was
thinking man it's just so great to go
back to a place that look
florida here in florida obviously ron
desantis can't completely control the
energy sector and we are dependent on
our deals international deals and all
that but it's like if the [ __ ] really
hit the fan and gas prices were really
going crazy and we really had shortages
and there were lines again like jimmy
carter's 70s and all of that stuff it's
like i have full faith
that the governor of the state that i
live in here in florida would be doing
everything possible to be managing it
properly and that the people the people
would be thinking through the issues
clearly and we wouldn't have mad rushes
and like true like
societal breakdown and it's like it's
going to be very different when it
happens in some of these other places
you take the bananas people of portland
and seattle and los angeles and now you
now they can't get gas either and
they're already burning the cities down
like what comes after that margot says
the energy secretary appears to be
running out of steam
a good one uh yeah that woman um
granholm it's like what was she before
this was she the maybe a deputy can you
search grand home what was she before
this she was a host on current tv but
before that
jennifer granholm she was a host on
current tv and i think maybe she was
like deputy secretary of something in
california or something um but it's
interesting because when they say this
thing
about oh we're just doing an energy
transition
politicians don't let a crisis go to
waste and that is what this is really
about i just have no doubt about it
right i just don't they want us on
uh
this they want us on this this green new
deal on the rest of it she was michigan
governor
she was michigan governor and now they
got they got gretchen whitmer so things
are not progressing well there either uh
olaf says maybe mayor pete could go on a
diplomatic mission to russia he could
ride his bike remember that video where
they saw pete riding his bike in dc
because they wanted it to appear that
pete was a big bike rider and then of
course someone else found video of him
his bike being driven somewhere that he
gets on the bike and goes
god we are governed by morons uh all
right guys reminder you can pre-order
don't burn this country
at daverubin.com
book and if you buy during the pre-sale
period it all goes to that first week
sale and i want to get on the new york
times best seller list not because i
give a [ __ ] about the new york times but
i just want to be able to throw it in
their faces i did it once they weren't
happy about it it would be even more
rewarding bizarrely two plus years later
to do it again uh if you want to play
along and get in the uh the chat section
comment section you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
and my full interview with harriet
hageman who as i mentioned uh is running
against liz cheney for congress in
wyoming and we do a ton
actually on energy
and and how we can not be so reliant on
places like russia which are led by bad
guys like vladimir putin who according
to joe biden are invading places like
russia uh i think you'll dig the
interview the full thing up ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com and with ads
over on rumble and youtube all right
that was a monday show i feel good about
monday shall we have lunch today
gentlemen
we will have lunch today i'm off to
record probably the first third of don't
burn this country audiobook i'll be a
little hoarse tomorrow but i'll have
some tea with honey i will do my job to
the best of my ability and then in
closing despite the fact that vladimir
putin is invading russia we just must
keep moving forward that is the
important thing don't worry everybody
joe biden's in charge let's go brandon
see you later